hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to toilet escape now get
ready for a horror adventure unlike any
other it's my personal opinion that
pretty much anything can be terrifying
given the right circumstances it's just
that I so happen to have my opinion be
wrong a long time collect all five
toilets and find the exit press shift to
run I'm not gonna bad whoa what the [ __ ]
run do I need to run flush what do I
need to run from I know I need to get I
know I need to get that toilet back
there but why why do I need to get the
toilet why am I in this place why am I
in bathroom hell the [ __ ] does that mean
I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna try to
get oh [ __ ] yeah alright then this was a
goddamn dead end okay so I need to go
back and I need to go get the toilets
disappear Lee whoa what [ __ ] oh no
yes no well oh no that was nothing I
thought that was actually something for
a second there well I I think I almost
died why why is there no escape
why am I actually kind of creeped out by
this even though I'm trying to get
[ __ ] toilets alright you know what I
shouldn't put so much pessimism into
this I could actually believe I gotta
believe in the purpose I believe in the
heart of the toilet got to believe in
the heart of the cards oh boy oh boy oh
great oh good
well I mean I could try to hide in one
of the cubicles you have to knock before
you enter that's only polite and then I
could probably try to hide in the toilet
even though I don't know how I'm hiding
these toilets what am i stuffing these
toilets in my pants
this is like the Slenderman grandfather
clock scenario no [ __ ] about grabbing
that [ __ ] is that sound are you this is
where things get legitimately like weird
it's such a strange premise but I'm
actually kind of perturbed by it oh no
oh no hello can you lead me to the
toilet please
I gotta go real bad I gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here real bad oh hello okay flush
there's no toilet here okay well this is
a place where a toilet would be but it's
not here yet
I didn't get them in the right sequence
oh boy that's gonna be annoying I have
no [ __ ] idea where this place is
oh boy right then what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is happening what the [ __ ] was that
I don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
I don't know what you're talking about
enough legend anything holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] okay all right that's bad I
was running towards it not away from it
that's why I wasn't getting any better a
my headphones are falling down my face
hi Ron juice
I'm a diary I can't fix my goddamn
headphones stealth fix okay all right
well this is oh this is a big old bag of
dick says it the eyes I'm back to where
I [ __ ] started oh great
oh okay so I think if I'm not mistaken
oh I don't know what that is track me
down from what how did I end up in this
hell what kind of toilet base crime did
I do
geez ooh oh okay here we go got one yeah
I don't think I can do either of those I
don't have the longevity for it I have
no idea where the [ __ ] I'm going no idea
I know I know except for the toilet I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know can't hide I get that I'm not
trying to I'm trying to run like the
scared little baby that I am if I could
run faster I would I'm limited in my run
ability oh is that a toilet that's a
toilet okay so if I get this one now
then I know where the last one is I've
seen it before so I've even get back to
some sort of landmark that I might be
able to worm my way back this boy down
sorry I can't run now would be the time
to run it's a big glowing turn monster
Hey oh god am I going towards the dead
ender I [ __ ] [ __ ] no no no no no no
no no no you can't flush me down oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
go go go please go breathe
please don't let me go down to goddamn
dead end or [ __ ] breathe and run okay no
escape that's fine
oh my god how many of you are there oh
[ __ ] did I just yes I got all five I got
five you can't say I didn't can you uh
give me some privacy here hey [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
five I got all five that it's [ __ ]
okay I don't know what was going on she
was just standing there she was being
polite she was waiting till I was done I
get that that's that's understandable I
appreciate that
oh and find the exit oh okay all right
then fine then fine I get it I can't
hide from us I don't remember where to
go okay so maybe maybe it's like the
strategy where if you look at her him
her I don't know what but if you look at
them they can't move God do okay you try
that see how that works out for you huh
go track me down by the smell alone huh
I get you I see how you operate way okay
so that is how it works I look at you
and you can't move
that's handy-dandy the future but I have
no idea where I'm going
yoyoyo this is a dead end oh okay ah
this is not good
don't move don't move don't move don't
move you're very lovely and I'm sorry if
I'm in the ladies room but oh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you whoa that one a little bit
speedy can't escape I know that I know I
know I know I know I'm not trying to do
either of those things
we'll stop Jesus it's like the slender
lady god damn it I'm stuck in a goddamn
loop here what do you have to do with
toilets toilets exit I don't have all
the toilets I can't do this well I found
the [ __ ] exit goddamn how would
anybody find this [ __ ]
I can't get through not enough toilets
[Music]
whoa she was unhappy oh boy okay alright
then whoa boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy growing boy growing boy needs his
toilets I'm trying to remember the
landmarks here but it's a little bit
difficult when I got to breathing down
my butt she's very upset about something
or other and I'm trying to quell her but
it's not happening whoa hello yeah [ __ ]
god damn it so the toilets are little
randomly generated okay because there
wasn't one there before and now there is
one oh come on oh come on
this [ __ ] oh well apparently I'm not
leet enough to get to the end of twilit
escape I I I thought this is gonna be a
really short game I literally don't have
any more time to get to the end again I
got five toilets why was I getting
toilets why was I in this world it was
this an endless hallway of bathrooms
getting toilets being chased by the
slender woman this is a lot of puzzle
pieces here and I can't fit the big
picture man I have no idea but if you
guys can figure it out maybe the end and
gives you some sort of like holistic
view of everything and there's like some
small key it's like the box for five
nights at freddys you open it and
everything's ready oh you open the lid
on the toilet and then a golden glow but
some things are just better laid to rest
so anyway that was toilet escape that
was actually pretty funny it did scare
me for a bit like legitimately it scared
me ah but the scares went away pretty
quickly so either way thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought of this down that
comes below and I challenge someone beat
this game I'll put a link did in the
description but beat this game and let
us know let us all know we all want to
know what the hell's at the end of this
game so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]